Ucrania ya es candidata oficial a entrar en
la Unión Europea.
Y estoy seguro de que la mayoría recordais
haber visto titulares como este:
(La UE otorga a Ucrania el estatus de candidato
en un “momento histórico” - Reuters)
De la misma forma que seguro todos, o al menos
muchos de vosotros habéis presenciado este
histórico momento:
La bandera de la Unión Europea ya ondea en
el Parlamento de Ucrania.
En cierto modo no cabe la sorpresa.
Tanto desde el punto de vista de la cohesión
política europea como, por supuesto, desde
el punto de vista militar, Ucrania ha hecho
méritos más que suficientes para ganarse
el estatus oficial de candidato.
No sólo por su incansable y valiente lucha
contra un invasor muy superior en fuerzas
sino también porque podemos decir claramente
que en la política europea hay un antes y
un después de la invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Al fin y al cabo, Ucrania fue atacada por
querer formar parte de la familia occidental.
Sin embargo, un momento, porque esto es VisualPolitik.
Sin lugar a dudas, haberse convertido en candidato
oficial a ser miembro del club comunitario
es un enorme espaldarazo para la motivación
y la confianza de los soldados y el pueblo
ucraniano.
Sin embargo, el camino hasta la integración
no será precisamente un tránsito fácil
ni tampoco rápido.
(Ucrania no tiene un camino fácil hacia la
adhesión a la Unión Europea
Los profundos desafíos que plantea el legítimo
deseo del país de unirse al bloque también
debe ser reconocidos)
¿Queréis saber a qué obstaculos se enfrenta
Ucrania para poder entrar en la Unión Europea?
¿Podrá realmente llegar a convertirse en
un país miembro?
¿Cuáles son los principales cambios que
tiene que llevar a cabo?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo
vamos a responder a estas y otras preguntas.
Y, por cierto, si os gusta lo que hacemos
ya podéis contribuir activamente a que VisualPolitik
siga creciendo y sobre todo siga mejorando,
con más y mejor contenido.
Así que si queréis apoyar este proyecto
y de paso recibir boletines, newsletters,
merchandaising y mucho más, ahora podéis
formar parte de nuestra comunidad en Patreon.
Os dejamos todoa la info en la descripción.
Pero dicho esto, vamos ya con Ucrania.
Seamos claros, entrar en la Unión Europea
no es como entrar en la OTAN.
Formar parte del club comunitario implica
incorporar un montón de leyes y realizar
un montón de cambios en el derecho, la política
y la economía de los países candidatos.
Por ejemplo, a Croacia le llevó ni más ni
menos que 10 largos años convertirse en estado
miembro.
Evidentemente el plazo depende de cada país.
A Finlandia, que ya tenía instituciones democráticas
y una economía de libre mercado asentada
le llevó 2 años.
Pero creo que todos, absolutamente todos convendremos
que Ucrania está más cerca de la Croacia
pre Unión Europea que de Finlandia.
Por ejemplo, para poder ser miembro del club
comunitario se tienen que respetar sí o sí
el artículo 2 del Tratado de la Unión Europea.
Un artículo que suele terminar siendo un
dolor de cabeza para muchos de los países
que quieren entrar en la UE.
(La Unión está fundada en los valores del
respeto a la dignidad humana, libertad, democracia,
igualdad, el imperio de la Ley y el respeto
a los derechos humanos, incluyendo a las personas
que pertenecen a minorías.- Artículo 2 del
Tratado de la Unión Europea)
La pregunta es, ¿cumple Ucrania con todo
esto?
Pues…
A ver, cómo decirlo.
Creo que todos sabéis que en VisualPolitik
condenamos rotundamente la invasión rusa
y que nos solidarizamos con Ucrania en su
estoica resistencia.
Pero, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
No seríamos objetivos si pintasemos al país
de color rosa.
Al fin y al cabo, si lucha por ser el país
más pobre de Europa es precisamente por algo.
¿No os parece?
(Hoy por hoy, tanto la política como la economía
de Ucrania están muy lejos de los estándares
occidentales.
Por ejemplo, su economía está muy intervenida
por el Estado, existen controlres de precios
y unos pocos oligarcas millonarios monopolizan
los sectrores estratégicos de la economía
nacional.
Oligarcas que, por supuesto, de una forma
y otra tienden a ser protegidos por el propio
aparato público.
De hecho, la corrupción en el país es rampante.
Según Transparencia Internacional Ucrania
es el segundo país más corrupto de toda
Europa después de Rusia.
Y no se puede decir que existan muchos controler
para intentar frenarla.
Todo esto es lo que explica que Ucrania sea
exageradamente pobre para los estándares
europeos.
Para que os hagais una idea hablamos de un
país cuyo PIB per cápita fue en 2021 de
apenas el 40% del PIB per cápita de Bulgaria,
que es actualmente el páis más pobre de
la Unión Europea.
Y por supuesto, con la guerra las cosas se
han puesto mucho peor.)
Queridos amigos, amigas, Ucrania tiene que
hacer taaaaantos cambios que algunos expertos
estiman que el periodo de adhesión puede
durar entre 10 y 20 años.
[Una eternindad]
Ahora bien…
Exactamente, exactamente, ¿cuáles son las
principales reformas que Ucrania tiene que
llevar a cabo para convertirse en un país
miembro?
¿Cúales son los principales obstaculos?
Pues…
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(EL DIFÍCIL PROCESO EUROPEO)
A ver, si tuvieramos que definir de alguna
forma a la Unión Europea podríamos hacerlo
con una palabra: burocracia y normativas interminables.
Así que el llamado proceso de adhesión implica
que los países que quieren formar parte de
la UE tienen que adoptar primero toda la normativa
comunitaria de golpe.
Hablamos de un proceso que en total se divide
en seis etapas: aplicación formal de membresía,
estatus de candidato, preadhesión, negociaciones,
ratificación y, finalmente, integración.
Pues bien, tras su ratificación como candidato
oficial, Ucrania acaba de entrar de lleno
en la tercera etapa: la preadhesión.
(Durante esta etapa, Ucrania o cualquier otro
país candidato tiene que acordar junto con
la Comisión Europea la llamada “estrategia
de preadhesión”.
Esta estrategia consiste en fijar una serie
de directrices para que Ucrania incluya en
su jurisprudencia las reformas administrativas,
políticas y económicas que le permitan al
Estado aplicar las leyes europeas.
Y no hablamos precisamente de un cambio menor,
si no de más de 130.000 páginas de legislación
europea que ahora Ucrania tendrá que introducir
en su sistema político.
Y evidentemente eso es mucha, muchísima legislación
y un costosísimo proceso de intentos cambios
en todas las estructuras del país.)
[Nadie dijo que fuera fácil]
Por supuesto, la economía no es una excepción.
Ucrania tendrá que poner patas arriba y cambiar
por completo su modelo económico para desarrollar
una economía de mercado funcional y libre
que pueda operar sin restricciones en el mercado
común.
Y, esto es mucho más fácil de decir que
de hacer.
No olvideis que Ucrania es un país que procede
del antiguo bloque comunista, esto es la más
dura Unión Soviética, y que nunca ha llevado
a cabo reformas profundas en su sistema.
Pero de todo esto hablaremos en un momento.
La pregunta ahora es, ¿entonces es que Ucrania
parte de cero?
Pues bien, lo cierto es que no, no parte cero…
Pero casí.
Ucrania está asociada con la Unión Europea
a través del Acuerdo de Asociación, firmado
en 2014 y que está en vigor desde el año
2016.
En virtud de este acuedo, el recientemente
convertido en el país más especializado
en Javelines del mundo, ha ido implementando
poco a poco algunos cambios durante los últimos
años.
(El Acuerdo de Asociación de Ucrania con
la UE obliga a Kyiv a emprender reformas legales
- Atlantic Council)
Este acuerdo, por cierto, tiene mucho pero
que mucho que ver con la deriva que han tomado
los acontecimientos.
Y es que veréis, gracias a este acuerdo la
economía ucraniana comenzó a girar a toda
velocidad del este hacia el oeste.
Esto es, desde Rusia y la llamada Comunidad
de Estados Independuentes hacia la Unión
Europea.
De hecho el comercio con el bloque comunitario
supuso ya en 2020 más del 40% de todas las
exportaciones ucranianas, 8 veces más que
las exportaciones a Rusia.
Hablamos de un proceso que ahora, además,
con la invasión de Putin lejos de frenarse
se ha acelerado todavía más.
Fijaos.
(28 de abril: La UE suspende los aranceles
a las importaciones de Ucrania durante un
año.
Kiev lo agradece.
Euroactiv)
(29 de Junio: Ucrania y la UE firman un acuerdo
de liberalización del transporte por carretera.
El acuerdo elimina la necesidad de que los
transportistas ucranianos obtengan permisos
para entrar a la UE.
- The Kyiv Independent)
Incluso, por fin se ha vinculado la red eléctrica
de Ucrania con la red europea.
Fijaos.(1 de julio 2022: Zelenskiy dice que
Ucrania ahora está exportando electricidad
a la UE - Reuters)
Sea como sea, el caso es que según palabras
de la propia Úrsula von der Leyen, gracias
a este acuerdo de Asociación, Ucrania habría
implementado ya cerca de un 70% de la legislación
y los principios europeos…
(Por ejemplo, entre otros muchos cambios,
se han mejorado los procesos de contratación
pública; las estadísticas oficiales se han
aproximado a los estándares europeos y se
ha comenzado a reformar por completo el mercado
energético, el cual hasta ahora estaba totalmente
controlado por el estado.
Incluso se ha desarrollado una administración
digital.)
Sin embargo, echad el freno, porque hablamos
de Ucrania.
Y, ¿cómo decirlo?
Las cifras de Von der Leyen, no se las cree
ni ella misma aunque se beba 3 litros de Coca
Cola.
La distancia que aún separa Ucrania de los
estándares europeos sigue siendo simple y
llanamente abismal.
¿Quéreios algunos ejemplos concretos?
Pues fijaos:
Antes veíamos que según Transparecia Internacional
es el segundo país más corrupto de Europa.
Pues bien, eso es tan solo el principio.
En el índice de libertad económica Ucrania
ocupa el puesto 130 de 177, está situada
entre países como Uganda, la India o la propia
Bielorrusia de Aleksandr Lukashenko.
En el índice Doing Business del Banco Mundial
está en el puesto 64.
En el índice de Libertad Humana ocupa el
puesto 98, practicamente a la par con Burkina
Faso, Kazajistán o Mozambique.
En el Rule of Law Index, que mide la calidad
judicial, el puesto 74; en el índice de libertad
de prensa el puesto 106 y en el índice de
calidad democrática el 86.
Lo miremos por dónde lo miremos Ucrania está
muy lejos del club europeo.
Y sí, gracias al Acuerdo de Asociación no
se parte de cero pero el camino por delante
es largo, muy largo.
Y, ojo que no solo hablamos de aplicar la
normativa europea.
Con eso en Ucrania no bastaría.
¿Por qué?
¿Queréis saber exactamente a qué escollos
se enfrenta Ucrania?
Pues…
Atentos.
(UN RETO COLOSAL)
Una vez termine la guerra y Ucrania pueda
centrarse al 100% en su reconstrucción - en
todos los sentidos, tanto física como económica,
social y política - el gobierno de turno
tendrá que poner patas arriba el país para
cumplir los requisitos de acceso a la Unión
Europea.
Y lo tendrá que hacer en un montón de frentes
al mismo tiempo.
Tendrá, por supuesto, que poner en marcha
las reformas que exige Bruselas, pero también
tendrá que volver a poner en pie al país,
empezando, claro está, por las propias infraestructuras
básias.
Es evidente que un país destruido fisica
e institucionalmente tendrá practicamente
imposible entrar a la Unión Europea, haga
las reformas que haga.
Sería demasiado caro.
Por eso cuándo pase la guerra el gobierno
ucraniano tendrá que esforzarse no sólo
en cumplir con la legislación comunitaria
y las peticiones de Bruselas.
También tendrá que actuar en estos dos frentes:
norar al hablar de todo un candidato a formar
parte de la Unión Europea.
En otras palabras, que al final las instituciones
europeas tendrán que poner en marcha una
especie de Plan Marshall para apoyar la reconstrucción.
(La Unión Europea creará una plataforma
para la reconstrucción de Ucrania.
La plataforma se utilizará para determinar
las necesidades de inversión, coordinar la
acción y canalizar los recursos, dijo Von
der Leyen.
Euronews)
El reto aquí es conseguir que este plan de
recuperación se aplique sin que el dinero
termine en los bolsillos de los oligarcas
que desde la caída de la Unión Soviética
han controlado la economía del país.
Porque evidentemente si la Unión Europea
destina un montón de dinero…
Que luego no sirve para nada, eso pondría
muy cuesta arriba el proceso de adhesión.
Bruselas parece confiar en que Kiev lleve
a cabo un amplio programa de liberalización
económica…
Pero, ¿realmente lo hará?
Está por ver.
Con todo esto no es lo más dificil.
(Lo más dificil es que Ucrania tendrá que
cambiar por completo su naturaleza de país.
Como ya hemos dicho, tendra que aplicar la
legislación comunitaria, pero con eso no
basta, también tendrá que poner fin a la
corrución estratosférica, y, por ejemplo,
tendrá que crear, entre otras cosas, un nuevo
sistema judicial que realmente sea garantista.)
Todo esto, queridos amigos, son cosas muy
fáciles de decir pero muy dificiles de llevar
a cabo.
¿Cómo puede Ucrania dar un giro de 180 grados?
¿Lo permitiran los oligarcas?
Y ojo que hablamos de un país que tiene cientos
y cientos y cientos de miles, millones de
jovenes emigrantes a lo largo y ancho de toda
Europa con destrezas profesionales y en muchos
casos buena formación académica.
Jóvenes que podrían llegar a jugar un papel
clave en el proceso de reconstrucción económica
e institucional que el país necesita llevar
a cabo antes de poder acceder a la Unión
Europea.
De hecho, seamos claros, sin atraer a la diáspora
es muy difícil que Ucrania consiga en un
periodo de tiempo razonable el nivel de prosperidad,
riqueza y desarrollo necesarios como para
completar su adhesión a la Unión Europea.
Pero, claro, para que puedan retornar, invertir
o montar empresas hace falta sobre todo dos
cosas: seguridad jurídica y mercados abiertos.
La pregunta es, ¿cómo conseguirlo?
Pues bien, hay quien dice que una forma de
conseguirlo sería emular el modelo de las
Zonas Económicas Especiales de Dubai, como
es el caso del Centro Financiero de esta ciudad.
Allí son jueces británicos quienes forman
a otros jueces e imparten justicia siguiendo
un marco de derecho especial, garantista y
muy atractivo para las empresas e inversores
extranjeros.
Ahora bien, ¿es esto realista?
¿Cabe alguna remota posibilidad de que sea
posible?
Pues… probablemente no, pero casos como
el del oligarca Rinat Akhmetov [PRON: Rinat
Ajmétov], paradójicamente, dan ciertas esperanzas.
Akhmetov, para quienes no le conozcáis, es
el hombre más rico de Ucrania, y un empresario
que siempre tuvo conexiones cercanas con Rusia
y con los entornos prorrusos de la política
ucraniana.
De hecho, ha sido el principal financiador
y líder en la sombra del rusófilo “Partido
de las Regiones” con el cual llegó a ser
diputado en la Rada Suprema.
Pues bien, atentos a esta declaración:
(“El mal no puede quedar impune.
Los crímenes de Rusia contra Ucrania y nuestro
pueblo son atroces, y los culpables deben
ser hechos responsables.
[…] Esta demanda es uno de los primeros
pasos legales internacionales contra Rusia
para detener sus crímenes, la destrucción
de la economía ucraniana y el saqueo de los
activos ucranianos”.
- Rinat Akhmetov, oligarca ucraniano)
Sea por dinero, por tener futuro en Ucrania
o por un repentino amor a su patria, o por
todas estas cosas a la vez, el discurso de
Akhmetov, propietario entre otras muchas cosas
de la famosa acería Azovstal, ha cambiado
radicalmente.
(Como él, muchos otros oligarcas prorrusos
están sufriendo multimillonarias pérdidas
patrimoniales por culpa de la invasión rusa.
Sin ir más lejos, el patrimonio de Akhmetov
se ha reducido desde su pico de 16.000 millones
de dólares en 2012, a unos 4.200 millones,
cuatro veces menos, según datos de Forbes.
Pero por contradictorio que pueda parecer
esta situación podría tener un lado positivo.
Muchos de los grandes olicargas ucranianos
han visto como una proporción relevante de
sus activos productivos se han hecho añicos
por culpa de Rusia; y con ellos buena parte
de su capacidad para influir en las comunidades
locales y en la política nacional.)
Es decir, la destrucción de buena parte de
su riqueza y de su influencia, junto a la
asistencia internacial y el cambio de prioridades
de Kiev puede hacer que estos oligarcas terminen
aceptando cambios en las reglas de juegos
para convertise en empresarios en un mercado
competitivo.
Pensad que si Kiev quiere realmente entrar
en la Unión Europea va a tener sí o sí
que poner coto a todos estos oligarcas.
Digamos que es muy probable que la reconstrucción,
la presión social y la seguridad nacional
valgan mucho, muchísimo más que los sobornos
y las presiones de estos oligarcas.
Oligarcas que, además, tendrán que expiar
su pasada inclinación prorrusa, con lo que
no sería extraño verlos enarbolar de repente
la bandera de la Unión Europea y las reformas.
En síntesis, para poder convertirse en un
miembro de pleno derecho de la Unión Europea
Ucrania tendrá que convertirse en una democracia
de cierta calidad;
tendrá que adoptar una economía de libre
mercado;
tendrá que introducir en su derecho y luego
aplicar la extensísima legislación europea;
tendrá que reconstruir sus infraestructuras;
tendra promover tasas de crecimiento importantes;
acabar con el poder de los oligar; y cambiar
por completo sus instituciones.
Una lista de tareas larguísima y muy pero
que muy complicada.
Pero, un momento, porque ni siquiera se trata
solo de Ucrania.
Para poder admitir como miembro de pleno derecho
a un país tan grande y con tantas dificultades
puede que la propia Unión Europea también
tenga que cambiar.
Me estoy refiriendo, por ejemplo, a cosas
como las reglas de unanimidad.
(En muchos campos la Unión Europea exige
la unanimidad de todos los países miembros
para poder sacar adelante diferentes iniciativas.
El problema es que la Unión Europea se está
haciendo tan grande que eso resulta cada vez
más complicado, sobre todo cuándo tenemos
en cuenta las enormes diferencias que existen
entre los países miembros.
Y, para colmo, Ucrania sería un poderoso
aliado de Polonia, un país que no se lleva
particularmente bien con Bruselas.)
Y, ojo, que este es un riesgo del que algunos
líderes europeos ya hablan abiertamente.
Sea como sea, ya lo veis, la entrada de Ucrania
en la Unión Europea, si es que llega a producirse
algún día, será un proceso muy largo, muy
dificil y sujero a muchas condiciones.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿crees que Ucrania terminará integrándose
en la Unión Europea?
¿Conseguirá Kyiv realizar todas las reformas
políticas y económicas necesarias para convertir
a Ucrania en un país homologable a los miembros
comunitarios?
Déjanos tus preguntas aquí debajo, en los
comentarios.
Y si te ha gustado este vídeo no olvides
darle like y suscribirte a nuestro canal para
no perderte ninguna novedad.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.